Como decía la canción, ¡no estaba muerto,
estaba de parranda!
Queridos amigos, amigas, el peronismo argentino,
que se vio entre la espada y la pared tras
las PASO del pasado mes de agosto, parece
ahora preparado y a punto para competir una
carrera electoral en la que ya se han roto
todas las previsiones.
Sergio Tomas Massa, el abanderado peronista
al que se le auguraba una catástrofe electoral,
es ahora el líder de una épica remontada:
(encontré en cada uno de
ustedes la energía que nos permitió que
creciéramos casi 15 puntos
desde la primaria a hoy)
Ahora bien, si algo ha quedado claro, es que
nada, pero absolutamente nada, está escrito.
En las primarias, la gran sorpresa fue Javier
Milei, y ahora, en primera vuelta, la campanada
la ha dado Sergio Massa.
Así que para el balotaje, para la segunda
vuelta, hay mucha incertidumbre, salvo por
el hecho de que el peronismo está frente
a una de sus remontadas más increíbles de
su historia, una que se está produciendo
en un momento económico absolutamente crítico
para el país.
(23 de octubre 2023: La sorprendente victoria
muestra la notable resistencia del peronismo)
(23 de octubre de 2023: Sergio Massa, el ministro
de Economía de Argentina que logró lo impensable:
ganar la primera vuelta en un país con casi
un 140% de inflación.
BBC)
(23 de octubre de 2023: Argentina: el candidato
peronista Sergio Massa frena la ola ultraderechista)
Amigos, la recuperación electoral del peronismo,
algo con lo que nadie contaba, genera ahora
nuevos interrogantes:
¿Podrá Massa triunfar en la segunda vuelta?
¿Qué necesita para lograrlo?
¿Qué representa este candidato dentro del
peronismo?
¿Qué proyecto tiene para la Argentina?
Pues…
Todo esto y más lo vamos a ver a continuación.
¡Arranquemos!
En 2019, la fórmula Alberto Fernández - Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner venció en primera
vuelta a la candidatura de Mauricio Macri,
lo que llevó nuevamente al poder al peronismo.
Un movimiento que ha gobernado el país 16
de los últimos 20 años.
Sin embargo, en esta ocasión, la mala gestión,
la pandemia, el shock externo por la guerra
en Ucrania y la inflación galopante pusieron
al gobierno - y por extensión a todo el movimiento
- contra las cuerdas.
El país se encuentra - otra vez - sumido
en una durísima crisis.
Para colmo se produjeron auténticas batallas
campales en el seno del propio gobierno.
Así que podemos decir que entre unas cosas
y otras la presidencia de Fernández ha sido
un auténtico desastre.
(no fui escuchada y
en un país de carácter presidencialista
como es este está claro que el que
decide siempre es el presidente, para
bien o para mal)
Como veis, la otrora poderosa Cristina Fernández
llega al ocaso de su vicepresidencia como
si se tratase de un perfil ajeno al gobierno,
mientras que el propio Alberto Fernández
es hoy un presidente tan ausente de la agenda
pública que se da por hecho su retirada de
la política.
Sea como sea, en ambos casos su nivel de popularidad
está por los suelos.
Y eso es un buen reflejo de lo que ha sido
el gobierno argentino durante los últimos
años.
Fijaos.
Cómo podéis ver entre el 70 y el 80% de
los argentinos tienen una imagen mala o muy
mala de estas dos figuras políticas.
Y de hecho, pese a que Alberto Fernández
es el presidente, la sensación es que desde
hace varios meses la Casa Rosada parecer tener
un solo dirigente: Sergio Massa.
Y es que, veréis, para afrontar la crisis
que atraviesa el país y hacer frente a la
ruptura total de la coalición de gobierno,
tanto Alberto como Cristina, presidente y
vicepresidenta, acordaron en agosto de 2022
crear un superministerio de economía que
unificaba varias carteras.
Al frente estaría Sergio Massa.
De esta forma le dieron prácticamente las
llaves y el timón del estado.
(estoy convencido lo conozco a Sergio
hace muchos años vamos a transitar
exitosamente
con todos y con todas incluidas
a eso los convoco para eso lo convoque a
Sergio, cuya
capacidad y coraje
me consta
y estoy seguro que lo va a hacer muy
bien)
Así comenzó el camino de esta especie de
antihéroe al que ahora los argentinos parecen
estar perdonándoles los desastrosos números
que se han cosechado en materia económica
durante el último año.
Un año dónde hemos visto una devaluación,
una inflación galopante y un sinfín de problemas
de todo tipo que el nuevo super-ministerio
no ha podido enfrentar.
Eso sí, a diferencia del caos que era el
gobierno de Fernández, Massa se ha mostrado
mucho más activo.
(5 de septiembre de 2022: Sergio Massa anunció
dólar soja a 200 ARS y aseguró 5000 millones
USD: las claves.
Cronista)
(10 de octubre de 2022: Massa viaja a EE.
UU.: se reunirá con el FMI, el Banco Mundial
y participará del G20.
Ambito)
(26 de abril de 2023: Por el dólar y la inflación,
Sergio Massa convoca a gremios y empresarios
a negociar 90 días de estabilidad.
Clarin)
(1 de mayo de 2023: Con guiños a Sergio Massa,
la Confederación General del Trabajo respaldará
una renegociación con el Fondo y apuntará
a los empresarios y a Javier Milei.
LaNación)
Es evidente que toda esta actividad no dio,
precisamente, un buen resultado.
Pero pese a ello desde su toma de posesión
Massa ha tenido una agenda frenética.
Cada semana tenía un anuncio, un acto público
o una política nueva para anunciar.
El objetivo ante todo, era mostrar que el
super-ministro tenía muchos planes en marcha.
De esta manera, poco a poco Sergio Tomás
Massa se convirtió en la cara visible de
un gobierno derrumbado.
Era el único que daba la cara, por lo que
gremios, movimientos sociales y gobiernos
peronistas provinciales no tuvieron otra figura
en la cual refugiarse.
Pero amigos y amigas, para entender cómo
Massa se fue colando por las grietas del peronismo,
debemos primero entender su naturaleza, su
historial y su tipo de hacer política.
¿Quién es realmente Sergio Massa?
¿A qué ala ideológica del peronismo representa?
¿Hasta qué punto podemos hablar de un candidato
accidental?
Pues…
Atentos.
T1 (UNA PERSONA, DIFERENTES ROSTROS)
El 12 de julio de 1924, durante los juegos
olímpicos de París, Luis Brunetto, con tan
solo 23 años de edad, logró convertirse
en uno de los primeros argentinos en obtener
una medalla olímpica.
¿Su especialidad?
El salto triple, una de las disciplinas más
complejas del atletismo.
Pues bien, hoy, casi 100 años después, Sergio
Massa es el máximo exponente del salto triple,
cuádruple y hasta quíntuple.
Durante su carrera política ha sabido ser
liberal, kirchnerista, anti-kirchnerista,
peronista disidente… y prácticamente cualquier
otra cosa que os podáis imaginar.
Digamos que su ideología es algo flexible.
Sergio tiene varios principios, y si en un
momento determinado estos nos gustan, probablemente
nos pueda mostrar otros.
(La carrera de Massa se inició en los 90s,
militando en la UCeDé (Unión del Centro
Democrático), un partido de ideología liberal-conservadora
que se posicionaba como una tercera fuerza
a nivel nacional.
Incluso llegó a ser presidente de la Juventud
Liberal en la provincia de Buenos Aires entre
1994 y 1996.
Y aquí fue cuando podemos encontrar su primer
salto: en 1999, ya en las filas del peronismo
-que en aquel momento seducía al liberalismo
con la figura de Carlos Menen- llegó a ser
electo Diputado Nacional por esta plataforma.)
Luego en el 2001, cuando el peronismo se hizo
con el Ejecutivo tras la renuncia de De la
Rua, Massa pasó a conducir con solo 29 años
la Administración Nacional de la Seguridad
Social (ANSES), cargo en el cual lo ratificó
Néstor Kirchner, hasta el año 2007.
Para entonces, su perfil ya era conocido como
una de las grandes promesas peronistas del
momento.
(ubilados evidentemente está claro que
para este gobierno los jubilados son una
prioridad la decisión del presidente
primigenia fue resolver la situación de
los jubilados que en la argentina
después de 11 años no habían tenido
aumentos y estaban en situación de
indigencia)
En 2007 pasó a ser Intendente de Tigre, una
localidad de casi 400 mil habitantes clave
en la Provincia de Buenos Aires.
Sin embargo, tan solo un año más tarde,
en 2008, Cristina Fernández de Kirchner lo
llamó para convertirse ni más ni menos que
en su jefe de gabinete, cargo que, por supuesto,
lo situó como una persona clave dentro del
gobierno kirchnerista
Pese a ello, Sergio duró poco en la política
nacional y en 2009 decidió volver a la gestión
municipal en Tigre.
En aquel entonces, este movimiento seguro,
seguro que pareció una “pérdida de categoría”,
pero lo que Massa perseguía era la construcción
de su propio poder territorial.
De esta forma, poco a poco, Massa fue creando
su propia liga de intendentes, y jugando con
la idea de ser un peronista moderado en contraste
a la narrativa kirchnerista.
En 2011, no solo llegó a obtener la reelección
como Intendente, sino que pasó a ser una
de las autoridades locales más votadas de
toda la historia argentina, ganando con el
73% de los votos.
De esta forma, en 2013, su figura representaba
un potencial relevo al kirchnerismo, lo que
se ratificó con la creación de su propia
plataforma política: el Frente Renovador.
Una ruptura importante entre Massa y el kirchnerismo
se produjo cuando Cristina Fernández quiso
promover alguna clase de reforma constitucional
que le permitiera reelegirse por segunda ocasión.
Massa fue uno de los voceros, dentro del peronismo,
más críticos con aquella idea.
Finalmente, cuando Cristina Fernández tuvo
que abandonar el poder en 2015, Sergio Massa
pasó a la ofensiva para tratar de conquistar
al peronismo desencantado con el tramo final
del gobierno kirchnerista.
Lo hizo dando un saltó más, no solo porque
se presentó a la elección presidencial,
sino porque tomo como principal rival al kirchnerismo,
a quien le dedico profundas críticas durante
aquella campaña.
(pasado queremos convocar con humildad y
generosidad a todos los sectores de la
política a discutir políticas de estado
a plantear después de esta elección que
viene un tiempo en el cual hay que
abandonar las miserias las mezquindades)
(que por ahí nos dice están tomando el
control del estado están poniendo a
fulano a mengano yo voy a barrer a los
“ñoquis” de la Cámpora que no quiere
dejar
como parásitos en el Estado)
Sea como sea, en esas elecciones Massa pese
a lograr más del 20% de los votos en la primera
vuelta, estos no fueron suficientes para llegar
al ballotage.
Mauricio Macri terminaría haciéndose de
la presidencia, lo que abrió una nueva etapa
en la carrera de nuestro protagonista.
Su idea era convertirse en el principal referente
del peronismo, ahora como oposición a Macri.
Para ello, fue el propio presidente quien
trato de promoverlo como un opositor “responsable”,
hasta tal punto de llevarlo al Foro de Davos
en 2016 como parte de su comitiva oficial.
(creo que es muy importante que
demos la… que tengamos la capacidad de
dar el mensaje de que la Argentina a la
hora de salir al mundo puede salir
gobierno y opositores con un único
mensaje)
( me acompaña uno de los
líderes más importantes de la oposición
en argentina a Sergio Massa del partido
peronista con serias posibles de
terminar siendo el que conduzca el
partido peronista en los próximos meses)
Sin embargo, está convivencia política duró
poco.
En 2017, el Frente Renovador de Massa sufrió
una debacle electoral importante.
En año 2019, Sergio volvió al ataque y amagó
con la posibilidad de ser candidato a presidente,
sin embargo, en esa ocasión dentro del peronismo
se creó una plataforma unitaria con un solo
objetivo: evitar la reelección de Mauricio
Macri.
(creo que tenemos
que hacer el esfuerzo de construir lo
más grande posible un frente para dar un
nuevo gobierno a la argentina en ese
contexto mi candidatura presidente puede
superar cuatro años)
Massa pasó entonces a liderar la lista de
diputados de aquella coalición, que condujo
la fórmula Alberto Fernández – Cristina
Fernández.
Fórmula que logró hacerse con el gobierno
en la primera vuelta de las presidenciales,
desbancando a Mauricio Macri.
Pues bien, en esa nueva etapa, Massa pasó
a ejercer la presidencia de la Cámara de
Diputados.
Era una especie de agente intermedio entre
los partidarios de Cristina y los de Alberto.
Por ejemplo, en marzo de 2022, la facción
kirchnerista del gobierno se negó a votar
a favor del acuerdo con el FMI, por lo que
Massa tuvo que manejar los tiempos y el debate
con bloques de la oposición para no dejar
al país frente al abismo del default.
Luego, poco después, en julio de 2022, el
ministro de economía, cercano a Alberto Fernández,
Martín Guzmán, renunció a su cargo y dejó
al gabinete a la deriva, con un presidente
y una vicepresidenta que no se dirigían la
palabra.
Entonces Massa se hizo cargo de la situación,
y asumió una situación sumamente compleja.
Sergio Tomas Massa lleva ya 15 meses al frente
del Ministerio de Economía, y la pregunta
es, ¿Cómo se las arregló para que el peronismo
llegara a la elección presidencial con cierta
competitividad?
¿Cómo logró unificar al peronismo tras
de si en un contexto tan difícil?
¡Pues atentos!
T2 (DEL PLAN “LLEGAR” AL PLAN “PLATITA”)
Amigos y amigas de VPK, los argentinos suelen
atribuirse la invención de múltiples aparatos
modernos, como por ejemplo, el helicóptero.
La primera vez que se realizó el vuelo de
un helicóptero controlable fue en Buenos
Aires, en el año 1916, cuando el argentino
Raúl Pateras logró la hazaña en los cielos
de la capital argentina.
Sin embargo, la palabra “helicóptero”
tiene una connotación oscura en la jerga
política gaucha.
Todos recuerdan como en el año 2001, el presidente
De la Rua tuvo que ser evacuado en helicóptero
desde la terraza de la Casa Rosada, después
de que renunciara en medio de una enorme espiral
de protestas y violencia.
Desde entonces, cuando un gobierno comienza
a tambalearse en Argentina, la imagen del
helicóptero comienza a ganar terreno en la
opinión pública.
Y por supuesto, en julio de 2022, cuando el
gobierno argentino estaba a la deriva, las
hélices en movimiento comenzaron a sonar
en la cabeza de varios dirigentes políticos…
Entonces, Sergio Massa se hizo cargo del super-ministerio
de economía con un objetivo muy claro: ¡Llegar!
Pero, ¿llegar a dónde?
Pues inicialmente, al final del mandato el
10 de diciembre de 2023.
Pero para poder ha cerlo Massa necesitaba
fondos, dinero con el que mantener en funcionamiento
la maquinaría el estado argentino y evitar
que la crisis se descontrole.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Buscó fondos hasta debajo de las piedras.
N8 (6 de septiembre de 2022: El BID acordó
con Sergio Massa y entrega u$s 1200 millones
para mejorar las reservas.
Cronista)
N9 (30 de marzo de 2023: Massa anunció un
“dólar agro” unificado y buscará simplificar
las cotizaciones para importar productos y
servicios.
InfoBae)
N10 ( 27 de mayo de 2023: Los objetivos de
Massa en China: ampliación del swap, BRICS
y reuniones clave.
Cronista)
N11 (4 de agosto de 2023:Argentina paga un
vencimiento al FMI con préstamo de Qatar.
DW)
Al mismo tiempo, en paralelo, Massa implementó
duras restricciones a las importaciones, para
intentar conservar la mayor cantidad de divisas
dentro del sistema financiero argentino.
Esto se tradujo, por ejemplo, en el establecimiento
del Sistema de Importaciones de la República
Argentina (SIRA), un sistema mediante el cual
el gobierno evalúa y aprueba caso por caso,
cada solicitud de importación.
Sin embargo, esto no solo opera como un control
de cambios ultra conservador, sino que ha
hecho que muchas empresas no puedan acceder
a suministros clave.
Y es todo.
El problema no es solo que el gobierno argentino
otorgue pocas licencias de importaciones sino
que encima liquida los dólares tarde y mal,
lo que le ha supuesto al banco central contraer
una enorme deuda comercial
(CHART 3: DEUDA DE IMPORTACIONES DE BIENES)
Esto es una especie bomba de tiempo que Massa
ha construido con tal de conservar algo de
oxígeno dentro de las arcas públicas…
Hasta las elecciones.
Sea como sea, más allá del coste futuro
que puedan tener maniobras como estas, lo
cierto es que Massa logró algo de oxígeno
para que el gobierno pudiera afrontar las
elecciones.
El Plan “Llegar” se convirtió -en plena
campaña- en el Plan “Platita”, lo que
se tradujo en una enorme expansión del gasto
público, para repartir a diestro y siniestro
un montón de subvenciones y prestaciones
a millones de argentinos.
(Después de quedar terceros en las PASO,
en las primarias de agosto, Massa y su gabinete
económico se lanzaron a la conquista de todos
los votos posibles, apuntando directamente
al bolsillo de los argentinos con el “Programa
de Fortalecimiento de la Actividad Económica
y del Ingreso”: un nombre elegante para
un enorme paquete de bonos, subsidios, aportes
y créditos sin precedentes en la historia
argentina.
Hablamos de bonos de 94.000 pesos (cerca de
100 dólares) para empleados informales, la
prórroga en el pago de aportes, IVA e Impuesto
a las Ganancias, un refuerzo de 37.000 pesos
para jubilados (cerca de 37 dólares), un
bono de 60.000 pesos (cerca de 60 dólares)
para los empleados del sector privado -obligando
a las empresas a otorgarlo-, y el congelamiento
de los precios de combustibles, entre otras
muchas medidas.
Toda esta vorágine asistencialista, según
estimaciones privadas, costó en tan solo
un mes, cerca de 1,3% del PIB.)
Y amigos, si pensáis que toda esta apuesta
de Massa se dirige solo a los sectores vulnerables…
Estáis equivocados.
El candidato peronista llegó a defender en
los debates el “PreViaje”.
(El PreViaje es un programa con el cual el
gobierno subvenciona el 50% de tus vacaciones.
Sí, tal cual como lo oyes.
El gobierno abre un registro para que las
personas suban allí sus boletos aéreos,
reservas en hoteles o excursiones guiadas,
y el Estado, tras verificar esa información,
te envía una tarjeta de crédito con un saldo
a favor equivalente al 50% de tus gastos.)
Los viajes de este tipo obviamente solo están
al alcance de sectores de ingresos medios-altos.
Estamos hablando de un país donde 6 de cada
10 niños son pobres…
allí el tesoro argentino subvenciona el fin
de semana de esquí de una familia en la Patagonia…
Ver para creer.
El caso es que todo este despliegue económico
generó importantes réditos para el candidato
peronista.
Por ejemplo, entre las PASO y la primera vuelta
de las presidenciales logró sumar casi 3
millones de votos.
El Plan Platita ha sido todo un éxito.
(CHART 4: RESULTADO ELECTORAL EN LAS PASO
Y EN LA PRIMERA VUELTA DE LAS PRESIDENCIALES
DE 2023)
Claro que este no es el único motivo del
repunte peronista.
Atentos.
T3 (CAMPAÑA Y REVANCHA)
Queridos amigos, amigas, os hago una pregunta:
¿Cuanto tiempo hace que no veis una buena
noticia de Argentina?
Desde luego en el terreno económico y político
quizás hablemos de años…
(CHART 5: Tipo de cambio del Dólar Blue)
Por ejemplo, desde que Massa asumió su cargo
como ministro de economía, el peso argentino
se ha devaluado cerca de un 230% y la inflación
anualizada alcanza el 140.
La foto electoral así vista resulta horripilante.
Y sin embargo, parece no afectarle demasiado
al candidato peronista y la pregunta, lógicamente,
es, ¿Por qué?
Pues…
Por un lado está el Plan Platita del que
os acabamos de hablar.
Pero además podemos encontrar otros dos factores:
Primero, Massa ha logrado presentarse como
un una especie de outsider.
Sí es el ministro de economía pero lo es
porque llegó para arreglar una crisis ajena.
El no tiene responsabilidad.
(Yo quiero dejar claro me hice
cargo de la emergencia cuando muchos
agitaban el helicóptero o la asamblea
legislativa.
No me metí abajo de la cama
porque amo mi país con el mismo amor que
el
11 de diciembre, en la producción y el
trabajo, voy a poner en marcha la
economía.)
En segundo lugar estuvo la campaña del miedo
en torno a Javier Milei.
El oficialismo peronista desplegó una enorme
batería de anuncios sobre como serían los
costos de vida si se cumpliesen las promesas
de Javier Milei, algo que caló hondo en los
sectores vulnerables.
Luego a todo esto se le sumó el malísimo
final de campaña del Partido de Milei, que
se dedicó a proponer disparates o medidas
que no les hacía sino parecer mucho más
radicales al tiempo que se desviaba la atención
de sus medidas estrellas.
Hablamos de cosas como la renuncia a la paternidad….
(Entonces el
proyecto es renuncia de la
paternidad la mujer cuando se entera que
está embarazada tiene 15 días para
notificar al padre y el padre debe puede
decidir si va a hacerse cargo del hijo o
no)
O la ruptura de relaciones con el Vaticano
en un país muy católico…
(habría que
imitar lo que hizo el presidente roca
esto es suspender las relaciones
diplomáticas con el Vaticano)
Seguro que ahora entendéis mejor el resultado.
Pero…
Más allá de ello, nos queda una pregunta…
¿Qué propone Massa?
¿Qué defiende para la Argentina?
Pues, amigos, para empezar, hablamos del ya
super ministro de economía, entonces es difícil
pensar que como presidente haría algo diferente
a lo que hace ahora, y de hecho eso queda
claro en su programa de propuestas, como estas
que podéis ver en pantalla.
(“El esfuerzo por reducir la inflación
se vio perjudicado por la pandemia y la guerra
de Ucrania y fue agravado por la sequía,
que significó una merma de divisas superior
a los US $20 mil millones (…) 2024 será
un gran año en el sector externo (…) Por
ende, se eliminarán las expectativas devaluatorias,
y por consiguiente su traslado a precios internos.”
(“Las reservas crecerán el año próximo,
luego de un año malo por la sequía, y con
la prospectiva de divisas por las exportaciones
de Vaca Muerta y el litio, entre otros elementos.
La flotación administrada de dichas reservas
por el Banco Central buscará garantizar un
tipo de cambio competitivo para estimular
la producción.”
Propuestas económicas – Unión por la Patria)
Básicamente, Massa confíaba en que todo
se arregle con algo de buena suerte, pero
sin cambios estructurales.
Es decir, más de lo mismo.
Sea como sea y llegados hasta aquí la pregunta
es para tÍ.
¿Quien creés que será el nuevo presidente
de Argentina?
De momento en la encuesta que hemos puesto
en comunidad ha arrollado Milei, ¿Estas de
acuerdo?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante,
ya sabes, dale a like y suscríbete a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.